if you're the Democratic party of New
York you are calling every union leader
and hack in the state and just shoveling
cash to people to keep Lee zeldin from
winning zeldin is the Republican
congressman from Suffolk County looks
like he could be the next governor of
New York a state that went for Biden by
23 points so what's that about well
simple violent crime it's out of control
particularly in New York City it's
destroying the city for example around 5
30 a.m this morning in New York a
homeless man with 25 prior arrests a
suspect in previous sexual assaults who
was out on the street
that man raped and robbed a 43 year old
woman who was out jogging in the West
Village a very nice probably the nicest
part of the city
again this guy was already wanted for
two prior sex crimes in one of them back
in April he sexually assaulted a
different woman who was out for a job in
October he tried to rip the clothes off
a 48 year old woman walking on the FD on
FDR Drive then he tried to rape her
so why was this guy walking around the
city this morning
and the real question is so this guy
just raped someone in the West Village
this morning where was Kathy hokel the
great defender of women
oh she's a woman she's a big feminist
did Kathy uncle say anything about this
today anything
it's one of the biggest issues going of
Interest no she said nothing she talks
about gun control which Newark has had
for 60 years
he had a stricter gun control in almost
any state it's nothing to do with gun
control this is rape and it's gone way
up in New York under Kathy Hopewell she
should be ashamed and she should lose
a lot of people feel that way a new Pew
survey of registered voters show that 82
percent of black Democrats believe
violent crime is a quote very important
issue you know who doesn't care about
violent crime people don't have to deal
with it only 33 percent of white
liberals care huh
what explains the difference there Larry
Elder is a former candidate for governor
of California he's also the host of
Larry Elder show on The Epic Times he
joins us tonight Larry thanks so much
for coming on so you'd think like if you
are a feminist candidate and Empower
women and girl power and all that stuff
and you're Kathy hokel and people are
getting raped in huge numbers in your
state you would say something about it
maybe
would you think so and that poll pretty
is uh very telling uh 82 percent of
white uh 82 percent of black Democrats
believe crime is a very serious problem
only 33 percent of white uh Democrats
feel that way and as you pointed out
that's because they don't have to face
the consequences but this is not not all
that surprising there's a website called
policemag.com
and uh those who were self-described
Tucker as very liberal were asked how
many unarmed black men did the police
kill in 2019 uh half of them thought the
police killed 1 000 unarmed black men uh
and five percent of them thought the
police killed ten thousand unarmed black
men now the answer according to the
Washington Post database was 12. so they
don't care they're not concerned about
crime but they're very very concerned
about the alleged systemic racism
against the police which is why you have
all these DA's all around the country
many of them backed by George Soros
money soft on crime castles bail letting
bad guys out on the streets because they
believe that they are victims of society
as opposed to people who are victimizing
other people most of them are black and
brown people living in the Inner City
well yeah and I'm just wondering I mean
the Republicans like Lee zeldon who are
running on this message are doing really
well why isn't every Republican this is
a civilizational issue why isn't every
Republican running on it
well all the ones that I've talked to
and I've been around the country on
behalf of people like uh Carey Lake and
people like a woman named Caroline Levin
who's running in New Hampshire in crime
is a big issue all around the country
and it should be but but I want to talk
a little bit more about this white
liberal thing because white Liberals are
often a clear and present danger to
black people it was white liberals who
pushed the welfare state that has
incentivized women to marry the
government and men to abandon their
financial and more responsibility to the
point now where you have 70 percent of
uh of black boys entering and girls
entering the world without a father
married to the mother it was white
liberals that pressured Banks into
lowering lending standards when we had
the recession a whole bunch of people
got wiped out black net worth fell
dramatically these are all white
liberals uh my let me just make a quick
point one of my friends is the economist
Walter Williams he wrote a column once
where he where he issued a proclamation
for giving white people of all the bad
things they've done in the past so that
white liberals can stop acting like
fools he said because you're hurting us
Malcolm X was right about them for sure
Larry Elder great to see you tonight
thank you